[Music]
coconut scented suntan oil it reminds me
of my first summer on the beach is that
your kids around here don't really have
bikes like this
yeah I'm not from around here people
call me a Minnesota like the city kind
of the events of that summer would
change my life you're 59 you new hopes
for this town next week that number will
dwindle I speak English I didn't
actually get him but some of you dig
deep enough I'm not good you see
discover the man or woman do always
minute babe was biting sorry have a guy
your majesty that's Brooke you got it
bad how do you do girl max you don't do
what you learn you Fame or what what
comes next we below all these choices we
have Oh miss Dora I just want to get
through today I receive
let's get into some trouble
[Music]
like Jane no no no no my River I lost my
bike
Wow Rocco would know he knows about
everything that comes in and out of this
town everything I'm looking for someone
this guy probably stand out we knew we
were gonna be right it's written in the
stars
you do have the chance of a cosmic
do-over
he's actually real the board is mine
until the universe reveals itself to me
it makes sense anymore what what does
that mean you've lost your nut kid over
a Viking good you got what it takes
then you always did
[Music]
most of the time
oh I came all the way out here for you
to tell me I already have what I needed
you know you came here with this magic
oh yeah they're clogged here we're
having fun jumping like that
[Music]
you